it is strange but true scandal has
rocked the world of award-winning nature
photography never heard of such a thing
that's right a Brazilian photographer
named Marcio Cabral took this amazing
photo of an anteater approaching a
glowing termite mound at night he took
this photo a while ago and people went
crazy for it the photo has been hanging
in a British Museum because it is
revered until they just discovered
Cabral used a stuffed anteater to take
the photo yes
it's fake it's a stuffed anteater so now
they're starting to question the
authenticity of other famous photos
Cabral has taken there's there's this
photo of a wild stallion racing across
the plain people are worried maybe it's
not good there's this Alaskan brown bear
hunting for food people are wondering
there's this photo of a family of
lobsters floating in the deep blue sea I
had no idea yeah there's a terrible I
was fooled
of course this famous photo of an angry
raccoon defending its young many people
at photo that captures the mysterious
timber wolf mating ritual people are
really as
there's this photo of a bandit box
turtle relaxing on a log no one saw this
one coming
and finally this photo of a charging
bull elephant no one no one
[Applause]
you